et avec léa salamé nous recevons ce
matin dans le grand entretien du 7-9 le
haut commissaire au plan président du
modem question réaction amis auditeurs
au 01 45 24 7 milles sur les réseaux
sociaux et l'application mobile france
inter françois bayrou bonjour bonjour
bonjour vous faites de la politique
françois bayrou depuis de longues années
maintenant vous faites partie de cette
majorité mais avait toujours depuis
l'élection d' emmanuel macron su garder
votre indépendance d'esprit et votre
liberté de parole alors expliquez nous
car on a du mal à comprendre
expliquez-nous ce qui se passe depuis
cinq jours dans la majorité à matignon
en région paca
dimanche le premier ministre annonce un
accord entre l air m et renaud muselier
pour les régionales donc en paca et il y
aura bien sûr des candidats lrm sur
cette future liste dit le porte parole
du gouvernement gabriela talent renaud
muselier déclare trois jours plus tard
qu'il n'en est pas question
et il conserve le soutien de son parti
les républicains votre ville fiasco
imbroglio on lit ses mots dans la presse
alors françois bayrou
expliquez-nous d'abord vous avez dit que
j'étais haut commissaire au plan c'est
vrai que j'étais président du mouvement
démocrate c'est vrai faut ajouter que je
suis maire de pau et un maire de pau
comme un président de région il a une
seule ligne de conduite c'est de
rassembler le plus largement possible au
moment de se présenter aux élections
pour avoir une base qui ressemble à sa
ville ou à sa région et pas aux cartes
de partis qu'on grandit d'ailleurs pour
les oubliés dès l'instant que on a été
élu et donc il s'est passé
ce qui à mon sens aurait dû se passer
depuis longtemps pas seulement dans
cette région mais dans d'autres
si j'avais été président de région et si
mon parti m'avait dit je vous interdis
de vous allier avec un autre parce que
nous on est dans l'opposition et pas
question de parler c'est horrible genre
de la majorité je vais les écouter mes
chers amis du comité directeur du bureau
politique de l'exécutif et de la
commission d'investiture
je suis président de la région tout le
monde connaît mes opinions
j'aurai des gens évidemment de ma
sensibilité politique et donc dans
l'opposition et je chercherai aussi des
gens dans la majorité
pourquoi parce qu'une région a besoin
d'être défendus et notamment et
lorsqu'il s'agit du rsa s'est pas passé
comme ça voilà un nom très bien alors
qu'il se sait les problèmes de qui j'ai
renault mise au lit car là que j'ai pris
lorsque vous appartenez lorsque vous
êtes à la tête d'une région
vous avez besoin d'avoir avec l'exécutif
des relations qu'ils soient des
relations de confiance de pouvoir
expliquer qui quels sont vos problèmes
ce que vous êtes et et l'aide que vous
attendez de recevoir ce aurait dû se
passer comme ça en tout cas moi ce sera
un jour et pourquoi ça a raté françois
bayrou
christian jacob dit
jean castex a reçu une gifle qui à mon
avis aura eu des résonances jusqu'à
l'elysée l'ailer finalement ont fermé la
porte et ils ont gagné
enfin je je suis pas certain qu'ils
aient gagné parce que ça n'est pas gagné
que de se refermer
chaque fois qu'on se referment au
contraire de ce que vous indiquez chaque
fois qu'on se refaire mon père vous
voulez m'expliquer ce que dans dans une
région comme la région paca avec des
difficultés qui sont les siennes et dans
d'autres voulaient m'expliquer pourquoi
on garderait comme seule référence la
carte d'un parti et son inscription dans
la vie politique nationale
j'ai toujours défendues pour les
municipales comme pour les régionales
parce qu'il ne vient on localise à la
sélection tour ça c'est vous qui
décrétait que seulement 10 cl est
rejouée important je vous rassure
alors remettons les déclarations à leur
place vous dites ça se fait au deuxième
tour et ben moi je vous dis au deuxième
tour ça marche jamais mais est ce que
cette affaire n'est pas navrante
françois bayrou parce qu'elles
instaurent un climat de désorganisation
généralisée ce n'est pas une question
rhétorique qu'on vous pose quand on dit
expliquez-nous on ne comprend pas ce
qu'il ya de l'indistinction on ne
comprend comment comprendre ces gens et
c'est sain c'est un climat navrant le
climat quand xavier bertrand alors ce
matin dit c'est de la traîtrise et du
déshonneur te 1 et il emploie le mot de
churchill contre hitler c'est à dire
vous avez voulu éviter la défaite au
prix du déshonneur vous aurez vous aurez
un bon mot de chercher le contre hitler
un peu
rien que ça xavier bertrand lors des
dernières élections régionales y a 6 ans
tout le monde tous les partis politiques
du champ démocratique et républicain
comme on dit français
se sont désistés ont appelé à voter pour
lui
y compris en sacrifiant leur siège la
gauche n'a plus de sièges dans le nord
pas de calais il dit xavier bertrand et
moi même j'ai appelé à voter pour lui
évidemment xavier bertrand dit je
respecterai toutes les opinions vous
trouvez que c'est ce qui est en train de
se faire en ce moment pardon vous
précisez pas françois bayrou soyons
soyons soyons juste vous ne précisez pas
qu'il réagit au fait que la majorité
venue envoyé face à lui eric
dupond-moretti babass etc
du coup il répond et ils disent à site
vous offre
je le cite emmanuel macron est un
calculateur froid est un calculateur
froid est un destructeur pour avoir
marine le pen second tour il lui faut
briser la droite
il met en place les conditions
objectives de la victoire de l'extrême
droite c'est un danger mortel vont
déploie sa sur le fond vous vous
exprimez éloquemment au soutien d'une
thèse qui est insoutenable
non non je ne tiens rien je vous en fais
les choses là non jour allez donc une
gestation l'a donc j'essaie donc
j'essaie de j'essaie de dire les choses
xavier bertrand a mobilisé tous les
courants politiques français lors de son
élection il ya six ans contre marine le
pen pour que tout le monde rassemble ses
forces pour le soutenir
aujourd'hui il dit ceux qui m'ont
soutenu nous en étions
ce sont des ennemis ce je vais je ferai
tout pour combattre ces destructeurs
bon alors en face de lui les forces
politiques mises en cause est accusé eh
ben ils disent on fait une liste
pour ma part je n'aurais pas choisi à la
place de xavier bertrand cette stratégie
là j'aurais choisi une stratégie de
rassemblement parce que je pense qu'il
n'y a rien de plus important dans l'état
où notre pays se trouve aujourd'hui
que de se rassembler pour essayer de
faire avancer les choses tout le monde a
l'air de considérer ou fait comme si
cette élection se passait dans un climat
ordinaire habituel dans lequel on se
trouverait au fond avec du beau temps un
ciel bleu et là on peut aller sur la
pelouse du stade de rugby pour pour
faire un match de rugby et se mettre d
baignons mais c'est pas ça la situation
la situation est plus grave dans notre
pays qu'elle ne l'a jamais été depuis la
guerre pourquoi était le plus grave
parce qu'il ya une épidémique est sans
précédent et parce qu'il ya un
effondrement de notre appareil de
production économique et donc des
emplois qui est sans précédent parce que
depuis trente ans la laisser s'effondrer
ça et vous pouvez pas dire que je dis ça
pour la première fois à votre micro
aujourd'hui j'avais passé ses nerfs de
plus au nom de cela et on va parler la
situation de la france qu'on vous a
aussi invité pour parler de ça mais
c'est vrai qu'on on voudrait essayer de
comprendre le climat politique et
surtout la stratégie est ce que c'est de
la tactique électorale est ce que
derrière ce que vous dites c'est à dire
il faut l'union parce que le pays va mal
est ce qu'il n'ya pas une volonté d'
emmanuel macron dans ce qu'il a fait en
paca ou en envoyant dupond-moretti face
à xavier bertrand dans les hautes france
qu'il n'y auront plus rien plus aucune
force politique plus haut qu'une
incarnation politique entre lui et
rassemblement national est ce qu'il est
en train de nous expliquer aux noms
l'union nationale le pays va mal que en
gros c'est lui ou marine le pen diaries
no alternative
écoutez il m'arrive assez souvent de
parler avec le président de la
république et je crois savoir à peu près
ce qu'il a en tête
qu'est ce qu'il a en tête il a en tête
que l'on puisse enfin enfin s'attaquer à
tous ceux qui minent notre pays depuis
des décennies et que pour l'instant on
n'a jamais réussi y compris à identifier
ce qui mine de notre pays depuis des
décennies on sait bien c'est cdc des
fléchissements
je parlais d'économie de l'appareil
productif industriel agricole de service
mais on a des problèmes très graves en
matière d'éducation nationale
on a des matières des on a des problèmes
très graves en matière d'adaptation à
l'emploi formation pour que pour que les
jeunes y aille et on a des problèmes
très graves en matière d'état on a un
état qui avec le temps a dérivé est
devenu plus bureaucratiques que que
soutient des initiatives de la société
ça c'est des problèmes qui sont des
problèmes vitaux
je sais pas comment on peut dire ça
question de vie ou d'effondrement mais
la bonne santé du débat public aussi est
un problème vital françois bayrou à ce
micro michel barnier dit en conscience
et gravement je le cite un il ne faut
pas jouer avec le feu ce pays a besoin
de clarté d'une droite républicaine
jeudi que ceux qui essaient de dynamiter
ou d'effacer tout ce qui existe entre
l'exécutif actuel et le front national
at il dit prennent des risques d'ouvrir
la voie quelque chose d'improbable et
que je ne veux pas voir arriver dans mon
pays ça que répondez-vous à michel
barnier qui n'est pas là dans une
tactique de court terme et qu'ils
formulent tout de même inquiétant les
patients with l'information mais en tout
cas il formule une inquiétude très
graves sur l'état de l'espace public en
france que répondez vous à cette
inquiétude
il y a quinze ans que à votre micro et à
tous les autres
j'ai formulé le diagnostic que l air la
droite qui venait de l'ump et le parti
socialiste étaient tous les deux en
situation de déliquescence
pourquoi parce que leur idée était d
idées qui avaient perdu leur originalité
leur pertinence leur leur définition par
rapport à ce qui était nécessaire
c'est-à-dire un grand rassemblement
centrale pour affronter les problèmes du
pays je vais prendre des exemples de
très très simple lorsque eric ciotti dit
il n'y a qu'une chose qui nous séparent
du front fera à peu près il ya une
qu'une chose qui nous séparent du front
national c'est notre capacité à
gouverner alors du point de vue des
idées
il ya là un aveu d'échec et deux au fond
de disparition
quelles différences en matière
économique en matière européenne entre
michel barnier que vous citiez à
l'instant et le président de la
république
ils ont mené ensemble la politique
européenne
quelle différence y at-il en matière
économique et la preuve c'est que le
premier ministre le ministre de
l'intérieur le ministre de l'économie
ils sont issus des rangs de l air c des
camarades de parti des compagnons deux
parties s'étaient pas des mêmes des amis
lointains ils étaient engagés 12 sous la
même étiquette avec la même carte dans
la poche et la preuve de cette
incohérence dans laquelle on se trouve
est con on refuse de voir la réalité en
face
xavier bertrand dit ce matin emmanuel
macron s'est jamais occupé de sécurité
il se trouve que le ministre de
l'intérieur chargé de la sécurité
s'appelle gérald am gérald darmanin et
qu'il était le bras droit de xavier
bertoni sanchez compris dans sa ruche
sur la sécurité vous parler de la
sécurité parlons-en parlons-en puisqu'un
policier a été tué hier lors d'une
opération anti drogue à avignon
cours de laquelle plusieurs autres
policiers ont été pris pour cible sur la
sécurité
jérôme fourquet à ce micro à ce micro
nous disait que c'était un sujet
absolument prioritaires pour les
français à un an de la présidentielle
il nous disait qu'en avril 2010 8 40%
des français faisait confiance à
emmanuel macron dans la lutte contre la
délinquance
aujourd'hui ils ne sont plus que 25 % à
lui faire à lui faire confiance sur les
sujets de sécurité comment vous
expliquer cela comment vous expliquer
alors que vous venez nous expliquer
qu'il y avait gérald darmanin au pouvoir
que c'est des gens de droite et c'est
emmanuel macron n'a pas réussi à donner
confiance en français sur des sujets de
la section que je vous indiquais par
cette citation de gea permanent c'est
qu' il n'est pas vrai qu'il y ait des
politiques différenciées sur ce sujet
entre le salaire et le gouvernement et
le ps parce que d'ailleurs tout le monde
se heurte aux mêmes difficultés
la sécurité alors la sécurité pourquoi
est-ce qu'on en est là parce que notre
société est en voie de décomposition
parce que le l'éducation l'éducation par
la famille les trafics de drogue tous
ces sujets là on les trouve dans chacun
dans sa région et chacun dans sa ville
et donc oui je pense qu'il ya de très
gros progrès à faire notamment en
rapprochant la police nationale des
responsables locaux et des mères en
particulier je pense que là la
distinction qui est faite depuis si
longtemps et qui est d'ailleurs légales
et constitutionnelles sans doute fait
qu' on pourrait beaucoup amélioré ce
cette question de présence sur le
terrain des forces de sécurité il ya une
deuxième chose il faut rapprocher les
attentes des forces de sécurité et la
justice
le les décisions de justice sont
naturellement commandé par l'appareil
des lois mais lorsqu'un policier arrête
un dealer et qu'il le retrouve dans le
quartier le lendemain comme vous l'avez
raconté dix mille fois sur vos antennes
alors il ya quelque chose qui est blessé
et atteint de ce point de vue là le la
sécurité elle ne peut être assuré que
par une entente nationale entre les
forces de sécurité et la justice allait
en fils on file au standard beaucoup de
questions françois bayrou sur votre
poste de haut commissaire au plan je
donne la parole à alain bonjour bonjour
bonjour monsieur l'homme bonjour
monsieur de bayrou bonjour je la
question n'est pas méchante mais je vous
sens plus fort en plan de relance
politique et stratégique que ce que vous
êtes chargé de le relancer plan
économique ou vie de ces terres etc
je vous ai entendu alors jouer sa mère
quel est votre sait quel est votre rôle
et j'espère qu'il n'est pas fictif
excusez moi merci alain pour pour cette
question qui fit que comme second parfum
comme souvent aux standards belle et
franche léhady de françois bayrou
m'avait invité quatre fois de suite pour
parler des productions du commissariat
au plan et je pense qu'on va le faire
encore aujourd'hui le au mois d'avril
j'ai proposé que nous ayons un
traitement de la suite de l'épidémie de
covin avec ce que j'ai appelé un plan
marshall pour la reconquête industrielle
et productive pourquoi parce que depuis
trente ans on a laisser s'effondrer
cette cette production en france je vous
donne un seul chiffre en allemagne
l'industrie c'est 25% du produit
intérieur brut en france c'est d'entre
11 et 12% moins de la moitié
et ça ne s'est pas fait en un jour ça
s'est fait par des suites de décision ou
de non décision au travers du temps et
j'ai chiffré à 250 milliards
le l'investissement qu'il faudrait faire
c'est pas de l'argent de subvention de
l'argent perdu
c'est pour reconquérir des secteurs
entiers de l'industrie dont nous sommes
exclus alors que nous avons toutes les
capacités technologiques industriels et
de recherche pour les voter ce plan de
250 alors vous avez vu peut-être parce
que c'est un peu c'est passé un peu
inaperçu quand j'ai proposé cette idée
une partie du gouvernement a dit non on
n'en a pas besoin et puis le président
de la république est allé à bruxelles il
dit oui il nous faut un deuxième plan de
relance
et de ce point de vue là oui c'est un
c'est un choix absolument essentiel nous
allons sortir dans les jours qui
viennent une note la même étude sur la
démographie du pays
la france a été pendant très longtemps
en tête de l'europe pour ce qui est de
la démographie de la vitalité du pays 2
et aujourd'hui cette démographie fléchi
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'il ya une perte de morale du pays à
la suite de l'épidémie mais probablement
commencé bien avant et donc ça doit
faire naître des politiques qui sont des
politiques de soutien à l'enfant de
soutien à la petite enfance de soutien
aux mères de famille qui travaille parce
que cette spécificité française d'avoir
plus de femmes au travail que d'autres
c'est quelque chose dont on est fier et
qu'on doit aider et on peut ainsi faire
le tour des sujets que nous avons traité
avec monsieur elle a une toute petite
équipe puisque nous sommes en tout et
pour tout sept équivalents temps plein
que ce n'est pas un plat fictif pour
assurer notre éditeur
ni de près ni de loin j'ajoute que c'est
de surcroît un emploi bénévoles aurélien
au standard qui nous amène de la ville
de nîmes bonjour et bienvenue on vous
écoute
si j'ai une question tout chaque mois
compte tenu du compagnonnage de route de
monsieur bayrou et du modem avec
monsieur macro je voulais savoir si en
2022 lui même ou l'un de ses proches
sera candidat à la présidentielle merci
aurélien pour cette question françois
bayrou 2022
non je suis un soutien du président de
la république je crois qu'il se
représentera et je pense que ça sera
bien pour le reste je n'ai jamais
accepté l'idée des phrases définitives
du genre moi jamais plus si c'était lui
mais si emmanuel macron venait à ne pas
se présenter pour quoi pas mode je veux
pas dire des phases de cet ordre
j'aurais naturellement des événements
c'est pas du tout ça qui m'intéresse
lorsqu'on est un citoyen on est un
citoyen engagé et je n'ai jamais mis de
limites à mon engagement et vous avez eu
la gentillesse de dire que j'avais
toujours conserver une liberté de parole
la liberté d'esprit qui sont ma raison
d'être est la raison d'être du mouvement
démocrate que j'ai alors est ce que
j'avais toujours une liberté de ton une
liberté d'esprit sur la question de la
levée des brevets joe biden dans la nuit
a annoncé qu' il soutiendrait la levée
des brevets sur les vaccins contre le
coc vide
la majorité elle a voté contre au
parlement européen cette levée des
brevets vous êtes pour vous êtes contre
vous entends tu as seulement la majorité
mais le la majorité des représentants du
champ politique français parce que sauf
les verts et les insoumis oui parce que
le ps a voté contre l air a voté contre
pourquoi parce que il n'y a de recherche
que si les chercheurs sont respectés et
récompensés quand ils trouvent et donc
il peut y avoir levé des brevets je
trouverais ça très bien pourvu que
le vaccin en question soit efficace et
garanties je trouverais ça très bien
mais naturellement il faudra indemniser
les laboratoires de recherche
vous allez on peut le faire par une
démarche internationale vous êtes
françois bayrou un fervent défenseur de
la proportionnelle vous étiez venu nous
le dira ce micro lors de votre
précédente venue dans le 7/9 ce combat
il est perdu pour ce quinquennat non
citoyen ou encore je dis vous dit le
combat est perdu pour le quinquennat non
non alors expliquez nous ma conviction
profonde c'est que on a vérifié depuis
des années qu'il fallait changer les
rapports entre l'exécutif et le pays
entre eux la décision centrale et le
pays et ce rapport qui est symbolisé par
la fonction présidentielle il faut en
face qu'on ait une vraie représentation
du pays voilà pourquoi je soutiens et
pas seulement moi puisque j'ai aimé
donner une assise natation et bayrou par
le président de république sur ça vous
dit vous affirmez n'ont pas suivi et moi
je vous dis je considère que ce combat
qui est essentiel n'est pas perdu et je
pense que le jour où on aura
rééquilibrer les rapports entre le
président de la république et l'exécutif
le président de la république et le
gouvernement et la représentation
nationale on aura fait un pas très
important pour que le débat soit
intéressant est considérée par les
français comme sincère alors qu'approche
le 10 mai prochain le 40e anniversaire
de la victoire de françois mitterrand en
1981 80 le rapport du clair sur le rôle
de la france dans le génocide au rwanda
en 94 pointe la faillite de la politique
française et met directement en cause
françois mitterrand et son entourage
même si le rapport ne complique ne
conclut pas à une complicité de la
france dans ce génocide
nicolas sarkozy s'exprime ce matin sur
la question longuement dans les aidant
dans le point il parle de l'aveuglément
dramatique qui étaient le fait d'un
petit groupe au plus haut sommet de
l'état
il cite le chef d'état major particulier
cellule afrique et le président
mitterrand lui-même
la france doit-elle aujourd'hui
s'excuser pour ce qui s'est passé
j'étais membre du gouvernement de
françois mitterrand françois mitterrand
étant président de la république
gouvernement d'edouard balladur
cohabitation et moi je n'ai jamais vu
d'un disent qu'ils aillent dans ce sens
là je pense qu'il est possible que
peut-être à l'époque une partie de
l'état major et était au courant ou en
tout cas est éludée quelque chose mais
pour avoir souvent parlé avec françois
mitterrand de ces sujets moi je n'ai
jamais senti la moindre indulgence la
moindre la moindre indifférence à
l'égard de ces choses alors je n'étais
pas dans l'appareil militaire je n'étais
pas dans les relations internationales
j'étais ministre de l'éducation mais moi
je n'ai jamais senti cela la france doit
s'excuser je sais pas de quoi s'excuse
devrait-elle s'excuser si les faits sont
établis la france dira qu'il ya eu des
erreurs à cette époque mais je n'aime
pas la politique perpétuelle de
l'excuser je ne je trouve que c'est
tellement confortable dans un fauteuil
25 ou 30 ans après de pointé du doigt
ceux qui étaient aux responsabilité je
ne je n'aime pas cette cette commande
ira cette démission devant l'histoire
françois bayrou merci d'avoir été au
micro d'inter ce matin je rappelle que
vous êtes maire de pau haut commissaire
au plan et président du modem merci
encore
il est 8 heures 46